when it comes to electric vehicle
manufacturing
few resources are as vital as lithium
over the past decade prospectors
unearthed troves of the lithium
chemicals
that power batteries but the shift
toward a cleaner economy is accelerating
and batteries play a central role
as a result demand for lithium is
expected to exceed supply
through 2025 car makers and analysts
say that more lithium is needed to
produce more batteries
at a faster pace and as china takes a
leading role in the battery supply chain
the us government is trying to boost
domestic supply of the metal
here's how lithium became such a hot
commodity
[Music]
lithium is scattered not only across the
us but
the entire world in the top lithium
producing country
australia miners excavate a mineral
called spogamine
which contains the metal and in chile
and argentina
companies extract lithium from massive
salt lakes by pumping water into the
ground
the extracted metals are mixed with
other elements to produce compounds
like lithium hydroxide and lithium
carbonate
these compounds are a key part of many
batteries
car makers and battery researchers like
dr geha you
value lithium because of its unique
chemical properties
polluting ions being so small they can
be very easily recharged
as they diffuse quickly during battery
charge discharge
lithium ions are also very lightweight
so batteries based on leading ions can
offer high energy
meaning that a lot of energy can be
packed in a small amount or small volume
of materials
these two properties energy density and
rechargeability
are the reason why lithium is found in
so many batteries
inside of all batteries are two major
components the cathode and the anode
compounds that contain lithium ions
transfer from one component when power
is drawn down
and they return when the battery is
recharging
and they can be charged like that
hundreds or thousands of times
so they have different kind of
degradation kind of mechanism
but leading eye is so small so they are
very stable so that's the reason why the
lithium ion can offer at least
these years of use scientists have spent
decades perfecting lithium-based
batteries
lithium was discovered in 1817 but more
than a century passed
before businesses used the chemical in
mainstream batteries
in the 1990s sony took advantage of new
lightweight lithium ion batteries
in a design for a handheld video camera
the result was the handycam
a smash commercial hit shortly afterward
rechargeable batteries began to appear
in laptops and smartphones
and batteries are increasingly used in
conjunction with wind and solar power
analysts like simon moores point out
that demand for the chemical is growing
as companies build bigger
battery-powered machines
people need more lithium today and in
the future than in the past
because you're going from lithium-ion
batteries the size of
your mobile phone to lithium-ion battery
is the size of your car
the entire chassis of an electric
vehicle is a lithium-ion battery so
there's an
order of magnitude bigger and as a
result you need an order of magnitude
more
of lithium supply which means that
mining companies around the world are
searching for lithium in the united
states
companies like lithium americas and
piedmont lithium are looking for
meadow-bearing spogamine minerals
in familiar places in the past lithium
from the tin spargamine belt of the
carolinas
was used in the production of both
medication and nuclear weapons
today prospectors are fanning out in
search of new deposits here
as well as in arkansas nevada and
california
the search is based on expectations of
consumer demand for electric vehicles
it takes four to seven years to build
lithium-ion it takes 24 months to build
a battery plant
these two parts of the supply chain they
don't live in the same time zones
and that is the major challenge is
matching the supply
when the demand is needed and at present
the industry has
has already failed to date even though
ev sales currently make up about two
percent of the us auto market
that share is expected to grow to 10 by
2025
according to morgan stanley and policies
coming out of washington could further
boost demand for battery components
president biden ordered a review of
domestic supply chains
for critical products that includes
semiconductors
key minerals pharmaceuticals and
advanced batteries like the one jews and
electric vehicles
they're strong bipartisan support for
fast reviews of these four areas because
they're essential to protecting and
strengthening american competitiveness
president biden's emphasis on supply
chain is driven in part
by geopolitics when it comes to lithium
only about one percent of global output
is both mined
and processed in the u.s china unearths
about 10 percent
china also processes about two-thirds of
the world's lithium supply
and dominates the global battery market
the us government has said that relying
on overseas sources for these materials
creates a strategic vulnerability which
means that a new hunt for lithium is
only getting started the race is on to
see who will supply the world
with this powerful metal
[Music]
you